so here we have 10 but this is a
different sample of 10 for what people
might be used to because most people see
10 in foil or they think it's tin foil
that they use to wrap up the chicken
mostly that's aluminium foil tin has the
symbol SN because it comes from the
Latin word stannum which means tin and
in fact if you go to Devon in the
southwest of England you'll find that
some of the town's there are called
stammer e towns because that's where
they used to mine and trade in tin tin
has a very old role in in trade and in
technology bronze which people used in
the old days was it alloy of tin and
copper which gave better swords then
then copper so if you were fighting with
somebody who had a copper sword and you
had a bronze one you won at least if you
were quick here we see a beautiful
sample of tin metal and you see it's a
really beautiful rod and it's packaged
in glass to stop oxidation but you can
see a beautiful silvery shiny metal tin
is also being used very widely for
coating the insides of iron and steel
containers wit for food that's why they
called tin even though they're made from
and but they had a thin coating of tin
on the surface and tin is also used very
widely for solder for putting together
metal components or electronic
components lovely sample of tin so we'll
put that back in and back into the draw